different pods of orcas actually have
different dialects so the same is you
know we speak English and Australians
speak English but Australian sounds
super funny a certain pod of orcas will
have its own dialect and they are able
to cross communicate but they can also
distinguish each other very very clearly
just audibly I'm wildlife biologist for
Escalante and this is the breakdown in
this day and age I don't think we'd ever
even consider making a positive movie
about orcas in captivity and that's
because we've learned so much about them
we understand that these animals are
highly intelligent now right here what
you're seeing is the intelligence of an
orca express is actually pushing the
coke bottles towards the young kid to
show him that he wants to play or I'm
not sure what he's indicating but this
is a sign of incredible mammalian
intelligence that being said in the same
exact frame you can see the bent-over
dorsal fin when we see orcas in the wild
we see it straight up it means they're
happy they're healthy they're not under
stress once they get captured and put
into captivity they bend down like that
and we've learned that that as a result
of them being very fatigued and
emotionally upset once the animal has
been in captivity and it's dorsal fin is
curled down it will never erect again
even if the animal is freed its
relocated back into the wild
it will never again go straight so this
is a physiological form of emotional
torture that you're seeing exhibited as
a characteristic like all fins the
dorsal fin is used for stabilization
thrusts and swimming when it's straight
up and down obviously it's going to help
the animal be more aqua dynamic slice
through the waves and when it's curled
over its gonna be a bit of a problem for
it no it's amazing about this movie
compared to many other movies is there's
nothing to say how real is this or isn't
it because it is real they are using a
real animal a real very well trained
animal and you're seeing it express real
characteristics it's quite beautiful in
helping us understand these animals even
they shouldn't have been in that
situation it may be that in this scene
the blowhole was exhibited in the sense
of like you let out a sigh and be like
uh-huh but that's not what's going on
whales don't do that and I bet whoever
was directing this movie when that
happened he was like yes that was
perfect the whale just sighed but the
whale didn't sigh it was just taking a
normal breath us as humans we
anthropomorphize that and start to feel
it as though it's a characteristic that
we would exhibit let's pause it there so
one thing that's really interesting that
I think most people don't realize is the
dexterity of these large mountains this
is a huge marine mammal it has no
fingers and toes it doesn't have the
ability to dissect things the way we do
as primates with our fingers but instead
it has the ability to do that with its
mouth it can carry that tiny little
piece of paracord that's connecting the
two coke bottles or cos when hunting say
like in South Africa when they chased
off all the great white sharks they're
so precise with using their mouth and
teeth that they were able to just take
the livers out of the sharks that they
were hunting and leave the rest of the
animal because they wanted the iron that
was in the livers so it's amazing we
don't think that this big goofy-looking
mouth could be used so delicately but
it's actually a very precise tool
in this scene what we see is Willie
blowing water at Jessie like he wants to
play and that's actually what he's doing
the animal is so intelligent that we
don't have to answer for more flies
characteristics on him we know that that
is actually what he wants which is to
play in this case it's a trained animal
for the movie but if it were to do that
say to its keeper it's probably because
the animal wants something or it wants
to play and that is incredible to be
able to tie an action to a result in
other words spit water and I get play
out of it
the amazing sign of intelligence
[Music]
see now it's beautiful about this is
what you're hearing on screen is actual
whale projection people have been able
to record what whales sound like by
putting microphones down into the ocean
and that's what they're playing they're
playing but what they're depicting is
the fact that Willy in captivity through
some kind of wall or barrier is talking
to his family out in the ocean now
whether or not orcas can communicate
above water I'm actually not sure these
are animals that have evolved to live in
the ocean and we know that sound travels
at a much greater rate than water that
it does in air as far as sticking your
head up into the air and communicating
to a pod of Orca that's out in the ocean
that seems a little more far-fetched to
me relatively new science has actually
shown that they can also distinguish
each other very very clearly just
audibly so in this case Willy is
communicating with this pod outside and
they know straight away that's him it's
not just like somebody be like hey buddy
and now they're gonna be like hey I hear
ya you know they know exactly who they
are it's like if you're yelling to your
mom across the house she knows who it is
that's yelling to her and that's the
situation that's going on right here
this is ace ventura - when nature calls
[Music]
rodents quadrupeds lend me
Jim Carrey calls all the animals and all
of a sudden the hunter in his hunting
lodge is looking around and firsta sees
a lion and then you hear in the
background an accurate African lion roar
and then he sees a zebra and sure enough
to be feared as ever as a background
they've actually sunk up real animal
sounds with the stuffed animal to make
it seem as though these mounted
creatures are coming to life freezes
frame we're splitting hairs at this
point right but we know that Ace Ventura
is in Africa and you've got an African
elephant mounted on the wall and yet
what comes bashing through the wall it's
an Indian elephant you can see here the
African elephant has got these big huge
ears and the Indian elephants got these
little small ears Indian elephants are
much smaller they have a much different
shape of their head their trunks are
different they don't have tusks anywhere
near like an African elephant I mean
they're really two very different
looking animals but it makes sense
because Indian elephants are much more
trainable they're the kinds that you
typically see in circuses they're much
more receptive to behavior modification
than your big African elephants and
behind that is a macaw from the Amazon
so although we're in Africa the first
two animals we see bash into the room
are not native to the African continent
at all behind them a call we've got
pigeons we've got a horse I'm seeing at
random in front of the zebra yep we just
got a horse here maybe we got a real mix
of animals here what the people making
this film have done you said get me all
the trained animals that we can and
let's put them all together in a room
you know how many biologist nerds like
forests are gonna actually watch this
and pick it apart and say oh these
animals don't occur in Africa this is
ridiculous the opening scene of Ace
Ventura 1 is a whole bunch of animals
working together as he hides up in his
apartment here we are I think in the
closing scene basically of the second
film and we've got all these animals
working together
what you're seeing here is the elephant
rears up is not a typical aggressive
elephant behavior right for an elephant
to rear up it's exposing its underside
which is giving it a vulnerable point if
an elephant is really aggressive what's
going to do is put its head down and
charge and trample you low to the ground
or push you into the ground using their
head or their trunk what you're seeing
instead is kind of like that circus
elephant behavior right where they rear
up they play with the ball it's kind of
a playful behavior but if you're a six
foot tall human being and an 18 foot
tall elephant rears up it's very
intimidating feeling and that's the
image they're going for here I would
never classify an elephant as aggressive
right they're protective they can be
very territorial and they could
certainly express aggression towards
humans but an elephant like most animals
if you leave it alone it's gonna leave
you alone so vultures don't swoop in and
attack things they're carrion eaters
they eat dead things so instead this
animals literally just coming in for a
landing right and it's keepers probably
right off camera like this and it landed
right on his arm
[Music]
you see humans and animals can live in
harmony incomes Ace Ventura riding an
ostrich right I grew up in Zimbabwe
which is where ostriches are native that
in fact my neighbors had an ostrich farm
so I spent a lot of time riding
ostriches as a kid as an adult man it's
pretty hard to ride an ostrich you have
to kind of do exactly what he's doing
and be way back and you just kind of
fall off after a very short amount of
time because a little kid when you weigh
like 60 or 70 pounds you can actually
stay on the ostriches for a lot of time
and it's a lot of fun ostriches don't
really like it they're not made to be
ridden their Birds does it totally
negatively affect them no but should you
go riding ostriches here and there no no
it's not good for
no it's not realistic but the idea that
you could just have this weaponized
skunk that you cuddle like your lap
Katan and pull up his tail and you just
rock it stink spray all over you is
absolutely hilarious not how it works
but absolutely hilarious
skunks obviously use that as a defense
mechanism when they're threatened if the
skunk is hanging out in your lap it's
clearly not very threatened so it's not
just gonna spray on sweaty blows like
the barrel of the gun the barrel is
gonna handle which is a little bit funny
this is a Christmas classic elf
I think he's walking through Central
Park here if I remember correctly and
sure enough he comes up on a very fat
very healthy raccoon hey what's your
name should you be seeing a raccoon out
in a very snowy environment like that no
today probably not that that being said
he's in New York right he's in Central
Park in New York City the raccoons will
climb up the sides of skyscrapers and
sleep in the tops of tall buildings
where the heating units are so they
actually tend to be really active all
year long so your odds of encountering a
raccoon in Central Park even in the
winter it could definitely happen
raccoons are nocturnal they're mostly
active at night but they're pretty
corpuscular meaning they're pretty
active at dawn and dusk as well so are
you gonna see them just out foraging in
the middle of the day
no it's less likely that's when
predators are out that's when it's scary
but keep in mind these are City raccoons
right they don't exhibit normal behavior
they can easily be out foraging in the
middle of the day my name is buddy hold
that there for a second look at that
thing I think a lot of people in North
America don't realize how cute our own
animals are right we like look at it
like these exotic elephants and lions
and tigers look at that face
nowhere has a raccoon like that it
thanks freaking adorable let's see what
happens my name is buddy
that's back up there for a second here
he is he's all cute right he's cuddly
he's got a sweet little smile and then
all of a sudden he starts to back up
right so that's good that's body
language to suggest that this raccoon is
nervous of whatever is in front of it
all the sudden he just goes into this
little like diamond raccoon face which i
think is still adorable maybe I
shouldn't maybe I'm sick in the head is
this a real raccoon in this exact moment
yes
but it's a real taxidermied one or it's
a real stuffed one that's been made to
looks gnarly and growly that cute little
cuddly trained raccoon is definitely not
making this face that you're seeing in
the scene and they just inserted that
one shot if you chased a raccoon into a
corner of an alley he would just run up
over the fence or run through your legs
if he was completely out of options
stuck in a cage or stuck in a trash can
or something like that that's when you
might see this super aggressive looking
body language someone need a hug so pro
tip don't hug raccoons for fun in
Central Park
I'm guessing how they got that shot as
they took a stuffed raccoon or raccoon
toy and literally threw it at Will
Ferrell's neck and had him fall
backwards and it's hilarious is that how
a raccoon would jump up and attack I
guess but in Central Park it would much
rather just turn and run away
we've got 101 Dalmatians
[Music]
dogs bark you know for a number of
reasons to sound an alarm to communicate
to call in this case he's marking to
reach another dog
[Music]
diversity now is like this game of
dougie telephone Dalmatian barks first
then it hits the dog on the barge
announcing the dog in the alley and I
assume it's good to continue passing the
message on to get across the city it
seems that's not really how dog barking
works right the dog barks at another dog
in the dog barks back a dog can bark for
hunger it can bark um it's sad you know
there's a lot of reasons the dogs make
noise but when they're all together and
the sound is kind of traveling from dog
to dog it's because they're all getting
each other excited all right
anybody's ever been on a farm knows
that's not really how it works right the
dog doesn't tell the horse to tell the
pig something can the horses or the
donkeys or the pigs sense when the dogs
are super excited or sad or being
punished
totally there's no simple answer to do
animals communicate you know sheep dogs
work with sheep cattle dogs work with
cows you know there's certain hunting
dogs that work alongside of horses these
are two different species that work
together it doesn't mean that they're
family it doesn't mean that they're best
friends it just means they know how to
respect one another say a cattle dog
that rides along the Cowboys horse right
that dog knows that he's in charge of
the cows but he's still commanded by the
person on the horse so there's a chain
of command that gets developed this
interspecies relationship although
initiated by man happens in the wild -
there was very recently a really cool
viral video of a badger in a coyote
going through a tunnel in San Francisco
going to hunt together nobody taught
them that those are just two animals in
the wild that figured out how to work
together these relationships do develop
with and without man but not exactly
like you're seeing it here we've got
jungle 2 jungle so the first time I'd
ever seen it was when I was a little Sam
Bob Wian boy who had just come to the
United States and I come from my own
jungle 2 jungle so of all the movies
that we're looking at this is the one
that actually no the best which is
hilarious maybe Domo
he does have a big tarantula just
walking on him which looks very
intimidating but as we know from the pet
trade are pretty common animals that can
be handled all that therefore I have
people all the time telling me these
incredible fables of the snake or the
spider that chased them you have never
been chased by a spider it has never
come after you the way it's coming after
Tim Allen in this film right they don't
do that
the spider wants to have nothing to do
with you it wants to get away did it
happen to run in your direction possibly
as a means to escape sure you can work
with them just like this this is as
weird as it sounds a training spider me
me I thinks the kids name kind of gently
tapping the spider on the butt goes into
the basket close to the basket I believe
that this kid actually did that whether
he did or was a stunt double I don't
know but that's what they're like
they're not big scary mean aggressive
animals typically just pretty calm
spiders
when tarantulas are agitated they will
shed their hairs because their hairs
have a terrible irritant on them and if
they get in your eyes when they get in
your mouth if you're a predator like a
bird trying to eat them that becomes a
big problem tarantulas basically have
two forms of Defense one is to bite and
the other to shed their hairs so
obviously these are CG animals right the
tiger CG the fishes CG and at the end of
the movie we kind of understand why but
this is very very real behavior in fact
of all the movies this might be the most
real behavior anybody that spent a lot
of time fishing out at sea knows that
you 100% do get flying fish that will
fly right into the boat hit people in
the face
now it's typically happening at night
flying fish are attracted to light they
migrate based on moonlight or your boat
light but sitting up here like this it
kind of looks like moonlight and the
flying fish will fly full speed and
pretty much kamikaze right into the side
of boats I've been hitting the chest
I've been hit inside of the head to have
flying fish fly into you like that is a
very real
thing flying fish fly for a couple
reasons the main one is predator
avoidance so when they're startled they
take off and they put out their modified
pectoral fins they act like a wing and
they let them glide over the surface but
they also use that as a means to migrate
to move fast distances across the sea
it's yours
I like the paper airplane rendition of
the flying fish right you throw it puts
it specs out and flies off never tried
it don't think it would work but
again
this happens this is a real thing I mean
I don't know that it happens quite in
that density that you're seeing it like
that you know it's more like one here
one there but you totally get groups of
flying fish nailing the sides of boat
and landing in the boat just like this
out at sea again it's all CG but it's
still pretty realistic that's what
happens with a big school of fish
congregate around a boat around the
ocean you get all this foaming water and
it's just kind of chaos just like that
I'm Forrest Galante and this has been my
breakdown
[Music]